They've known everything for years.
And it's amazing, isn't it,
how anyone who disagrees with them
has got to be just... crazy.
Lieutenant Shaw reporting as ordered, Sir.
What’s the fight even about?
I guess I just can't abide bullies, sir.
So your father threw a few punches
in his day.
Some of them at me.
some orders have come through.
Security escort for a Japanese scientist.
I'm so sorry, sir.
A Japanese scientist?
I think you’re here for me.
You'd like me to drive?
Why?
Am I'm making you nervous?
It's impressive.
Doesn't that make you
a little overqualified for this snipe hunt?
This what?
Wild goose chase,
Help! Hurry!
Help! Come on!
Oh my God!
Oh my God.
Help me get him out.
C’mon!
Before it comes back.
It is a dragon.
You want to do some serious science,
then we need backing.
Welcome to Monarch, General.
If we hide who we are
and what we're trying to do then....
What’s the point of doing it at all?
Kei,
It's over.
They don't trust either of us.
I don't care.
Yes, you do.
Oh my God.
Why would he have that in this file?
We didn't kill it.
Oh my God.
Oh my God!
Go, go, go!
Reach, Kei!
Reach!
You-
don't have to do this.
Mayday! Mayday!
I told you I've been here before.
I made it back.
Get me Bill Randa!
You disappeared during Operation
Hourglass in 1962.
20 years ago
Gestation will last about five and a half months
for the majority…
I tell you the truth,
You're just going to think I'm crazy.
Adventure
now begins as it searches for sources.
We interrupt this program,
to bring you breaking news.
Colonel Shaw?
We can get the hell out of here right now
and find out what really happened
with your dad.
Oh my God!
Stop!
Come on, baby.
Here we go.
Everybody in one piece back there?
Kentaro!
Run!
Come on, Get on the rock.
Wait, what happened to your centuries
of experience?
It's a Titan, May.
They’re like snowflakes.
Never came across two that were the same.
We build a bonfire,
we feed it .
Dinner time, you son of a b*tch.
Go!
The world is on fire.
I decided to do something about it.
Mmm-Hmm.
You want to help?
Monarch is wrong.
I think you and
I have a lot to talk about.
Come with me.
And you’ll know everything, I promise you.
My name is Colonel Leland
Lafayette Shaw The Third
and your base is now under my control.
Sir. Look-
Yes!
Exactly what do you think you’ll find in there?
Reach, Kei!
It won't be for the faint of heart.
I can tell you that.
So that's why you want to seal off their world.
I am sealing off their world.
Every portal.
I got you!
Don’t let go of me!
Cate!